エワンメスタンウェカンサマヤンバガワサッケースウィーラティカピラワットススミンニンゴーダーラーメアタコーバガワプッバンナサマヤンニワセッアーパッタジー
バランアーダヤカピラワットススミンピンダーヤパーヴィシーカピラワットススミンピンダーヤチャリットワパッチャバッタンプィンダパートパティッカントーイエナ
カーラケーマカッササッカッサヴィーハローテーヌパサンカミッティワーヴィーハーヤーテーナコーパナサマイエナカーラケーマカッササッカッサヴィーハーレサンバ
ウラーニセーナーサナニパンニャッターニホンティーアッダサコーバガワカーラケーマカッササッカッサヴィーハーレサンバウラーニセーナーサナニパンニャッターニ
ヴィスバーナバガヴァトーエタダホーシサンバウラーニコカーラケーマカッササッカッサヴィーハーレセーナーサナニパンニャッターニサンバウラーニコイダビククヴィーラティーティ
そこまでです
ある日 お釈迦様が カピラワットという村の町ですね
ニグローダという寺院です
そこにはね 住んでいました
サッケースというのは釈族の国ということで
この釈族の国のカピラワットというのは首都ですし
で そちらにお寺がありまして
ニグローダラーマっていうお寺ですね
で そちらにお釈迦様が住んでいましたし
そこでカピラワット町に入って托鉢をして
昼昼休みしようと思って
他のお寺に行ったんですね
そんなにニグローダラーマほどの大きなお寺ではないんですけど
カーラケーマカという釈族の人が作った寄付したお寺なんですね
そちらに昼休みでもしようかなと入ったんですね
その時 お釈迦様がものすごいたくさん
このお坊さんたちに住むためにいろんな用意しているのは見たんですね
座るとこやら寝るところやら
もうあっちこっちでいろいろ用意してあるんですね
ものすごいたくさん で
まあ一人でなんとか昼休みしようかなと思って
あまり誰も行かないお寺かもしれませんしね
行ってみたらそんなところじゃなくて
ものすごいたくさん 人々住むために場所を用意しているということ
そこでお釈迦様がこの
そのことを見て こういうことを考えましたと
サンバウラーヌコイデビククヴィーラティーティ
今なんかカーラケーマカ寺にはものすごいたくさん比丘たちが住んでいるようですねと思いましたね
まあそれで最初のところ
次に行きます
テーナコーパナサマエーナアヤスマーナンドサンバウレーヒビククヒサンディンガターヤサッカッサヴィーハーレチーハラカッマンカロティーアタコーバガワーサーヤ
ンナサマヤンパティサッラーナブッッティトーイエーナガターヤサッカッサヴィーハーローテーヌパサンカミーパサンカミッダーパンニャッテーアーサネイニーシーディ
ニーサッジャコーバガワーアヤスマンタンアーナンダンアーマンテーシーサンバウラーニコアーナンダカーラケーマカッササッカッサヴィーハーレセーナーサナニパンニャッターニ
サンバウラノコエッタビッコウビハランティーティ
サンバウラニバンテーカーラケーマカッササッカッサヴィハーレーセーナースナーニパンヤッターニ サンバウラエッタビッコウビハランティーチーバラカーラサマヨノーバンテーワッタティー
ティ
テーナコーパナサメーナ
その時お釈迦様がアヤスマーナンド
その時アヤスマナンドーアナンダ尊者がサンバウレーヒビククヒたくさん比丘たちと一緒にガターエサッカッサヴィハーレ
ガタというシャカ 釈族の人々みんな釈迦と呼ぶんですよ
シャーキャという言葉を使っていますね
ガタというシャーキャのお寺ですね
これも釈族の一人の人で
名前はガタですけど 彼が作ったまたお寺があります
そちらにたくさん比丘たちと一緒にアナンダ尊者がチーバラカンマンカロティ
衣を作っているんですね
大変行事でしょうしね
衣を脱いたり いろいろ衣を作るのは大変な仕事ですけどね
それをやっているんですね
たくさんの比丘たちと一緒に
それでお釈迦様が午後になって一人でいたんだから
このパティサッラーナウッティトというのは全く一人で禅定にでも入っていることを意味しますけどね
いて そこから起きて このガタ
釈迦の寺院に行くんですね
行って そちらにはだいたいお釈迦様にはいつでも座るところは用意してあるんです
お坊さんたちが集まるところだったら
自分たちが座ると必ず一つの場所は一番上のところはね
いつでも一つ用意しておくんです
お釈迦様が来るか来ないかと関係なく
必ずお釈迦様には座るところを用意しているのが昔の習慣でしたし
ですから どこへ行ったっても
お釈迦様はどんなお坊さんたちが一人いるところに行ったっても
お釈迦様には座るところはちゃんと用意してある
だからそれは昔の出家の習慣です
そういうわけでお釈迦様にとってはどこにでも何も遠慮なしに入ることはできるんです
お釈迦様は突然人のお坊さんのところに行きますから
いつ行くかわからないんですね
突然訪ねていく だからそこでまたもう焦ったり
いろんなこと言ったりすると困るし
で だからそうならないように
いつでもお釈迦様と一緒にいるんだということで
ちゃんと座るところを用意しておいて
自分たちがその部屋を一人だったら一人でその部屋を使っているんですね
そういうことのお釈迦様もそちらに行って
自分に用意してあった椅子に座りましたと
はい それで座ってアーナンダ尊者にこう聞くんですね
カーラけいまかサッカ坂の寺にはものすごいたくさん寝るところやら座るところなどなど
ものすごいたくさん用意してありましたと
たくさん比丘がそちらに住んでいるんでしょうかと聞くんです
聞いたら そうですよと
たくさん比丘たちはこのカーラけいまか寺院に住んでいるんだよと
今はチーバラカラー様よ
衣を作る時期ですよと
で 衣を作る時期っていうのは 1ヶ月間に決まってるんです
毎日衣の面倒をするのもやっぱりあまり認めてないんですね
例えばあの雨安居というこのことがありまして
雨季 3ヶ月間 どこにも行かないで一箇所に修行するという習慣がありましたし
で その雨季もインドの雨季なんですけど
だからどんな仏教の国でもその日にちに合わせてあの安居というふうな修行するんです
で 自分の国に雨季か乾季か
それとは関係ないんです
雨季であろうが乾季であろうが
インドのその雨季の時期になってくる
その日にちに合わせてあの安居に入ります
それで安居も 3ヶ月間で終わったら
また 1ヶ月間あの衣の月になっちゃうんですね
衣祭りというかね そのことをやっています
その月では信者さんも自分の村で 3ヶ月間住んでいたお坊さんたちはこれから出かけてしまいますからね
一応衣とかなんとか生地とかは用意してお布施たりはします
あれをまた 1年間使わなくちゃいけないんだからね
まあ新しい衣を作ろうかなとは頑張るんですね
それで衣を作っていくのはものすごい縫うところはすごいたくさんあります
ですからこの今ミシンですからね
30 分でまあ終わりますけど
すごい上手な人やっても 30 分ぐらいかかります
今もミシンでね まあすごい鋭く切れるハサミがあったり
1枚の生地なんかはいたも簡単に変えられるし
だから切るときでももう簡単に計算計って切ったりして衣を作ることができますけど
昔っていうのはそんなものではなかったんだから
生地の大きさを見て まあ無駄なくどういうふうに切ればいいかということをしなくちゃいけない
それで 1枚1枚この小さく小さく切りますからね
小さく小さく切って それをつなげてつなげてつなげて衣を作るんですね
だから小さく切るということも
やっぱりお布施する人々にとってもね
便利なんですよ だからほんのちょっとひときれあったって
それを差し上げれば それのワンカット取れるんでしょう
ですから そうやっていろいろ人の衣のカットを集めて衣にすることはできますし
とにかくすごい時間かかる作業なんです
ですから まあ手作業でやるとやっぱり 1日はかかりますよ
で ここはずっとありますから
2枚の 1センチ  2センチぐらいの 3センチかな
これと 3センチの幅で
こうやってこれずっと前に行って
また横に行って また上に行ったり
またいろいろ で かなりやります
これはこの一番少ないカット数で
それであのもともとカット数多いものもあります
で カットの枚数が変われば変わるほど衣で大変なものになるんですね
一番高い衣になってくると
もうほとんど 3センチ間隔でもう全部切って切って切ってつなげてつなげてあるんです
そういうことだから この 1ヶ月間も衣を作ったりします
だからお坊さんたちが朝早くから夜遅くまでそれしか仕事をしないというかね
それでお釈迦様が質問をしたら
アーナンダ尊者が答えて
それでまたお釈迦様がお話しするんです
ナコー アナンダ ビク ソッベティ サンガニカーラモ サンガニカーラト サンガニカーラマ タン アナユット ガナーラモ ガナラト ガナサンム
ディトソーヴァタ アナンダ ビックー サンガニカーラーモ サンガニカラトー サンガニカーラーマタン
アノユットー ガナーラーマトー ガナラトー ガナサンモディトー ケーナタン ネッカムマ スカング パヴィヴェーカ
スカング ウパサマ スカング サンボーディ スカング タッサ スカッサ ニカーマラービー バヴィッサティ アキッチラービー
アカシラービーティ ネータン ターナン ヴィッジャティー ヨーチャコー ソーヴァタ アナンダ ビックー
エーコー ガナスマー ウーパカットー ヴィーハラティー タッセータン ビックーノー パーティカンカン ヤン
タン ネッカムマ スカング パヴィヴェーカ スカング ウパサマ スカング サンボーディ スカング タッサ スカ
ッサ ニカーマラービー バヴィッサティ アキッチラービー アカシラービーティー ターナン エータン ヴィッジャティーここでお釈迦様はこう言うんですね
ネク アナンダ ビックー ソーヴァティ
これはあまり良いことではありませんと
ソーヴァティっていうのはいいことですよという意味で入ってますから
これはあまりいいことではないんだと
どっちですかと サンガニカーラーモ
サンガニカっていうのは集まり
グループということで
あんまり集まってみんなで集まっていることはアーラーモ好き
集合するのは好きということはあまり良くないんだと
アナンダです  自習を楽しむ
自習って何ですかね  グループで集まること
サンガニカーラーマっていうのは
それは楽しむ グループにグループでいることは楽しむ
自習を楽しむということ
サンガニカラと それに大変喜んじゃうんですね
自習を喜び それで自習の楽しみにふける
サンガニカーラーマタン アノユット
そればっかりグループのことをみんなで一緒にいることばっかり考えているということなんですね
それでガナーラーモ 同じ言葉をまた繰り返しちゃうんですね
ガナっていうのはこちら別宗にしていますけどね
私は日本語わかりません
だから自習 別宗はどういう意味かわかりませんですけど
自習の自分のグループで
別宗は他のグループのことじゃないかと思う
でもサンガ サンガニカアジレンの回向
サカカリサン こちらにはそんな意味は書いてないんですね
うん まあ一応あの他のグループという風に注釈書に書いてます
自分の仲間と一緒に楽しむことを
また他の仲間と仲良くして楽しむことも良くないんだと
それは良くないんだと
ソーワタアーナンダ ムシアーナンダ
ビクが あのサンガニカーラーモ
自分のグループとずいぶん楽しくて
その楽しみに喜びにふけて生活すると
あるいは他のいろんなグループと仲良くすることが楽しくて
もうたまらなくなっちゃって
それにふけて生活するとどうなるかというと
ヤンタンネッカンマスカン
ネッカンマという喜びがあるんですね
ネッカンマっていうのは
この欲から離れる喜びなんですね
えーと スリ 欲の楽 ネッカンマスク
で ネッ で ネッカンマっていうのは一応パーリ語ではまあかなり使ってる言葉で
あのまあ出家の意味もするし
で 出家としての喜びの場合もネッカンマというし
ネスカンマっていうのはこの
まあ一応離れることを意味しますね
それであの楽しみっていうのは 2つありまして
ものを得て楽しむというね
まあ見るもの 聞くもの
味わうものなどなど たくさんものを得て楽しむ方法もありますね
まあたくさんね まあ金儲けて
土地を買って 家を買って
車を買って またそうやってあらゆる品物
部品を買ったりして 音楽隊まで買ったりとかね
で それであの ものから楽しみを得る
家族がいて 家族から楽しみを得るとかね
で それはまあものに依存してものから得る楽しみで
まあそれ一つですね それはカームスカというんですね
欲の楽しみ で 欲の楽しみの場合は
この  まあそれは世俗的な世界ではやっぱりお金がなければ楽しくないんだとか
祖母がいなかったら楽しくはないとかね
まあ豪華な家がないと楽しくはないとかね
まあ高価な服でなきゃもう面白くないとかね
そうやって思っているのは世間世界で
で それについて仏教は何言いますかというと
まあそれの楽しみっていうのはわずかでしょうと
それは得るためには あなたはものすごい苦労しなくちゃいけないんではないかと
そう簡単に お金なんかは降ってくるわけじゃないし
だからお金得るためにはあらゆることをしなくちゃいけないし
時々悪いことまでしなくちゃいけないし
自分の命も危険にさらさなくちゃいけないことにまでなるんですね
で そう ものすごい苦労しなくちゃいけない
で 苦労したら必ずも財産に恵まれ
恵まれるかというと それもまたないんですね
もう頑張った分は金に恵まれる可能性もあるし
そうならない可能性もあります
ただ頑張っただけで儲からなかったっていうことも
大体五分五分ですね そこで苦労して楽しもうかなと思って苦労して金儲けようと思ったところで金儲からなかったら
ものすごいもう苦しんで悔しくて終わってしまう
それで もし万が一成功して豊かになったとしたらね
これすごい少ないんですよ
世の中であのすごい金持ちになるということはね
で みんな頑張ってますよ
みんな億万長者になろうとは思ってはいるんだけど
なる人っていうのは 6万人 に一人しかないと
ということになっちゃいますからね
ですから そうたとえそうなったとしたっても
それからその財産を維持管理守るというね
ことはもう大変なことなんですね
だから金持ちは一番この自分の命が危ないんですよ
で いつやられるかわからないし
なんかね もう南アメリカやらフィリピンやらそこら辺にもう旅行もできないというかね
で 行ったらもう捕まれちゃうし
だから結局金持ちなんですよ
時々そうやって人質というんですか
このまあ誘拐されますね
誘拐されて森の中でもうものすごい汚いところで
きついところで縛りつけちゃって
あの蚊がいるわ ヒルがいるわ
もうもう切りがない で
またもう食べたこともない
食べられないね ものすごい悪い食べ物を食べさせたり
殴られたりとかね いろんなことをたっちゃった
命拾いする だからいくらでもお金払わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうしね
まあ結構まあこの南アメリカのどこですか？よくやられるんですね
日本人は コロンビアそっちでなんか分からないんだけど
あまり日本のニュースでは報道しないということにもなってるんですね
で だから金持ちになるということで
なったならば これ少ない人々しかならないんですけど
なったならば それからもう自分の命まで大変危険なことになるんですね
それで子供にしたってのは
子供がいつ楽しいと思ったっても
やっぱりそれから子供にしても大変なんですね
もし誘拐されたらどうしようかというふうなことになってしまっちゃうんですね
で まあそうやっていろいろ問題っていうのはまあ起きますよ
で お金に対して 例えばこれ全部税金で払っちゃうとね
もう自分のものでなくなっちゃうんではないかというふうなお金の欲を出しちゃうと
まあサッチャーさんにみたいに逮捕されちゃうとかね
で だから計算してみたらね
まあ世界から社会から散々悪口言われたり
やがてもう逮捕までされたりしちゃうと
もうそれで人生はどうでしょうか
幸せですか 自分が成功したんでしょうかととは聞きたくなりますね
だからこのものをあって楽しもうというのは
まあそう簡単ではありません
で 俗世間ではそれにチャレンジしているんですね
もう まあ例えば 1杯の水もらう
あげますよ 100名ももう 10キロぐらい走ってこいと言っちゃうと
一杯の水のために はい
わかりましたよ  10キロ走って水を一杯喜んで飲むと
なんて楽しいかとその時は思うかもしれません
だってものすごく喉が渇いて
もうヘトヘト疲れてるんだから
水一杯でもものすごい
もうこの世この上ない楽しみを味わいますけどね
で そこで仏教の見方っていうのは
まあバカバカバカらしいではないかとね
そこを 10キロぐらいもう走らせて走らせて
それでヘトヘト疲れて
もうもうもう喉が渇いて
もうもうカラカラになって死にそうになったところで
もう天国に生まれ変わったような感じがするんですね
水一杯飲むと だから 世俗の人々の楽しみっていうのはそんなもんだと
だからみんなあの楽しみにものすごく執着しているんです
あの 10キロ走った苦しみは忘れちゃうんです
こんなに楽しみがあるんだから
もう一回走るぞと また走っちゃうということで
そういう風に この俗世間の楽しみはそういうものであると
それはカーマスカというんですね
欲の楽しみ それでネッカーマスカというのは
その欲から離れる楽しみで
物から離れる まあ結構ですよと全部処分していくんですよ
そうするとものすごく楽になっていくんですね
例えば例えば車を一つ持って持っている人が
それに対してはいろいろ苦しみっていうのはあるし
まあずっと駐車しておかなくちゃいけないし
それ払わなくちゃいけないし
いろいろものがあるんですよ
問題っていうのは だからどこでもどこでも行くときは
買い物やらなんだかんだ車で行けるかというとそれもないし
車で行ったとしてもそれからまた大変でしょうし
遠く止まってまた歩いて行かなくちゃいけないしね
で 結局電車で行く人よりは歩く距離が長くなる場合も当然あるし
で それでじゃあ処分するとすると
その瞬間あの大変なところは消えちゃうので
だから計算的に言うと
100キロ走って水を一杯飲むんだぞと
これは嫌やと思っちゃうと
その人は 100キロ  100キロじゃなくて 10キロ走る苦しみはなくなっちゃうんですね
それは楽じゃないかと
だからかなり苦労して苦労して踏ん張って
いくらかお金儲かる じゃあ儲からないことにするんだよと
もうお金はいらんと 離れますと言っちゃうと
ものすごい必死で もう侮辱されながら
貶されながら 怯えながらという
あの生き方は全部もうやらなくてもいいということになっちゃうんですね
ですから この依存しをしている品物からどんどんどんどん離れてみる
それはネッカマスカということなの
だから出家っていうのは
一発で全ての俗世間の仕事やら何から何までもう離れる
何一つもしない もうというよりも
そういう欲から離れると
物から離れるといて 家も家族も全部捨てて出家する
で 出家しただけで もう今まで味わってきた限りない苦しみというのは
それだけでも消えてしまうんですね
だからそうやって楽になること
それは楽しみというよりも楽になるんですね
刺激的な楽しみでいれば
それ分楽ですよと で 楽になることがネッカマスカというんですね
そういうことで このネッカマスカということが
それからパヴィレーカスカン
パヴィレーカスカンっていうのも同じ言葉なんですけど
この離れたという意味なんですね
いわゆる休みということなんですよ
いろんなまあ誰でも人間というのは
もう仕事から休み取ると
その休みの時間というのは楽しいんですね
ですから この まあちょっと休みましょうと言った瞬間から楽しみが生まれてくるんですよ
で ではまた仕事始まるまでいたら
またストレス溜まってくるんですね
真剣に仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだから
休みましょうと言った途端
ストレスがなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから この休みの喜びということで
いわゆる離れる喜びなんですね
[背景音]次の言葉はウパサマスカ
ウパサマっていうのは心の安定という意味なんですね
ストレスあると心は安定してないんですね
すごく動揺しているんですね
で まあストレスという言葉というと
パーリ語ではあんまりね
まあなんかあるといえばあるということですけども
パリラーという言葉なんですけど
この心がなんとなく燃えている状態でね
なんか火傷したような状態で
精神的に で おそらく今現代ストレスというのはそういう言葉かもしれません
なんかちょっと  波打ってるような状態っていうのも当てはまりますか
で その今のところは  いわゆる波打ってますからね
どうしたって  だから波の大きさっていうか
弱情のスカっていうのは
その波の打ってない あの静かなスカっていうのとったらいけないんですか？ だからパーリ語を基にするか
日本語を基にするかっていう問題ですけど
パーリ語はウパサマソックですけど
今ウパサマソックの説明をしようとして
一番近いっていうのは
その火の燃えてるようなって感じってこと
っていうのは  火が燃えてるような感じっていう意味ですか
底はないっていうことはウパサマソックはないです
わかりました  ウパサマスカっていうのは
この心の平安状態 安らぎの状態ですね
いわゆる心は まあこの物から離れて
それでは平安にはなりません
例えば出家しただけで
もう平安堕落だと そう簡単にはなりません
まあ自分持っているものはどんどんどんどん処分していくんだと
それだけで心の平安が得られるかというと
それはそれじゃないんですよ
なぜならば 物をたくさん揃ってもらって喜びましょうと思ったこと自体で
何か問題あるんですね
心に 思考の問題あるんですね
あれが欲しい これが欲しいと
あれがなければ楽しくないんだと
これがなければ楽しくないんだというふうに思っていた心の問題があるんですね
それで 最初にその人をやるべきことは
この得たものは捨てることなんですね
捨ててんだけど 心の状況はそのままなんですね
ですから それから心で欲しがっていた状態もなくさなくちゃいけないんですね
だから欲しいなのに処分するということはかえってきついんですよ
欲しいのにもう処分するんだよと
ですから このどれも道は決まっていて
欲しいんだからといって物に依存すると永久的にそのまんまでしょうし
苦しみだけでしょうし
だからもうきつくたっても
まず処分しなくちゃいけない
処分したところであー
やっぱり欲しかったなという気持ちが生まれてくる
それは心の欲でしょうしね
それで心も伸ばしてもらって
そういうものに依存しないように
心の欲をなくしてもらうんですね
欲と怒りを それで心は平安になってくるんですね
で 刺激はいらなくなっちゃうんですね
だからウパサマ・スカっていうのは
心の中から煩悩が落ち着いて
煩悩がもう落ち着いて消えて沈んでしまって
平安な状態に いわゆる波のない状態になってくる
次の言葉はサンボーデ・スカン
サンボーデ・スカンっていうのは
サンボーディっていうのは悟りのこと
こちらは声楽の楽しみと日本訳していますけど
お釈迦様の悟りはサンボーディといって
お坊さんたちの悟りにはアラカンというふうに使うような言葉もありましたけど
それに引っ張られて 後の仏教の世界でアラカンの弟子たちの悟りは完全じゃないんだと
言葉に惹かれてね そういうふうに言い始めて
ブッダの後を捨ててしまったって
ブッダが弟子たちに悟ろうと言っているんだから
あの悟りは正しくないんだと
というふうに 後でね 人々が言うようになってしまったんですね
それで宗派仏教が出てきて
大乗仏教が出てきて もう完全に仏教を捨ててしまって
また別な教えになってしまったんですね
それで この大乗という言葉が現れたインドの時点で
一つ疑問点にしたのは
このアラカンカなんですよ
アラカンカは完全じゃないんだと
そこで初期仏教の人々は
あんた方はどうやって知っているんでしょうかと
ということで 誰かさんが好き勝手に言って
お釈迦様はサンボーディでしょう
あんた方はアラカンでしょう
はっきりと言葉 2つあるんじゃないかと
ですから あんた方の方がレベル低いではないかと
そういうふうに決めてしまったんです
それでもアラカンには煩悩は全然消えませんよと
また偉そうなことを言ったりとかね
そうやって根拠はない
ただ自分の思いですね
思考も語って それで物別れになっちゃって別れてしまったんですよ
で お釈迦様は自分もアラカンだと言っているんでしょうし
普通はあまり言葉に引っかかったことはないんですね
煩悩なくしたら もうそれは悟りであって
アラカンであってという
アラカンという意味ももう完全という意味でしょうしね
もう完全になりましたと
サンボーディ ボーディっていうのはわかることで
ボーディといえば インド語で
インドの諸言語でわかったという意味で使っている言葉なんですよ
一般的には ですから 一般日常生活の中でもボーディという言葉は使えるんです
パン買おうと人がパン 3つ買ってくださいと子供に頼んだら
はい わかりましたと その場合もボーディという言葉を使いますよ
だから子供はすぐものを忘れちゃいますから
母親がしっかりと何回も言って
もう覚えましたか？と
わかった  3つでしょ うん
という子供は まあ 3つでしょうと
まあわかったと はい わかりましたと
で その意味でもインドの諸言語だったら
ボーディという言葉は使えるんですよ
で 例えば何か哲学的なことやら論理的なことやら
昔は教えるでしょうね
口で全部 それでいろいろ論争のことやら教えてあげて
弟子にも論争させて 先生と対話させちゃって
そこでやりとりやったりして
それで大体当たり前先生は勝ちますけどね
勝ったところで あなたはこういうところでこういうことをしたんだから負けたんではないかと
ですからこういう風に論争するしなさいよと
で そうやってまあ今度は生徒が勝つかもしれませんね
勝ったところはあんたの勝ちやと
ではもうわかりましたか？と
やり方は はい わかりましたと
もう大丈夫やと そういうふうにこの出来事
物事というのは身につく
自分で その時でも使う言葉っていうのはボーディなんですね
だからお釈迦様にとってボディという言葉だけ使うと専門用語で使っているんだから
もうちょっと誤解する可能性あり
ですから 八正道につけたこの正の字を入れたんですよ
サンマーボディ 本物の分かったことって何なのかと
こういう俗世間で一時的にあれが分かった
これが分かったではなくて
究極的な正しい学って何ですかと
ということで 正学という言葉を使っているんですね
だからこの宗派 仏教やら大乗仏教で言っている解釈とはもうまるっきりも関係ないんですよ
正学はすごい正しいレベルで
阿羅漢というのは正しくないんだと
それはもう不完全な悟りで
完全な悟りはもうもう正学だと
大乗仏教はそれに頑張るんだよと
というふうになっていて
結局もともとの教え捨てたんだからね
まあ菩薩になることさえもできなかったんですね
だから菩薩にならなくちゃあかんですよ
ブッダになりたければね
菩薩になるということは
もう大変な時間かかる仕事で
仏教を捨てて菩薩になれるということもまた不可能でしょうし
菩薩信仰なんかあるんだけど
大乗仏教では菩薩がいないんですね
菩薩ってなんか変な神ですよ
テーラワーダでは菩薩たちがいますけどね
ただ一生懸命自分で修行したり
徳を積んだり もういろんな能力を身につけようではないかと
もう大変な修行をしているんですね
テーラワーダ世界だったら
もうちゃんとした菩薩たちがいますよ
人間で で やがてブッダになりますよと
というふうに 将来というふうに思っています
それはもう菩薩行であってね
お祈りすることとかね
それは菩薩信仰であって
だからまあその人間で一生懸命菩薩行をやっている人々を信仰しているということだからね
まあレベルの低いのはちょっとあまりにも低すぎですよ
初期仏教はそういうことで
直接お釈迦様に当たってみる
一番最高なところに当たってみたら
お釈迦様は悟ってお釈迦様と同じ
みんな悟れますよというところで
平等的な立場にはなっているんですね
だからこれは見方次第ですけど
初期仏教の立場から見れば
そちらが一番上の方で頑張ってますね
で こういう間接的に裏口でなんとかまあコソコソということではなくて
玄関からも堂々と入ると
裏口からは仕事がいろいろあるんだったら入られますけど
皇室にしたってもね 玄関から入られるのは天皇陛下一人だけなんですけど
あるいは国賓で何かそれなりのそれでも入れてくれるかどうかはわかりません
決まりあるんですね どんな玄関で入るかっていうことはね
一番前の玄関で入るのは天だけであって
その時でもいつでもないんですね
それなりの儀式がある時だけ
それだけ他のところから入っちゃうと
そんなもんで 初期仏教はお釈迦様に直接座って
玄関から入って話を聞いて
その悟りを喜んで帰ろうではないかという
だからそれが間違ってるんだよと大乗のほう言ってるし
それぞれ見方ですけどね
そこでこの場合はサンボーディスカというこの悟った喜び
正覚の喜びという言葉を使っているんですね
ですから サンボーディっていうのは
お釈迦様だけに限った特別な悟りで
それは阿羅漢たちにできないんだという意味ではないんだ
サンボーディってサンマーという言葉を使ったのは
八正道にもサンマーという言葉を使っているし
八正道はサンマーでサンマー立ち方でしょうし
それで悟りもどうせ正覚になるんですね
日常生活では言ってる
わかってるんだ わかりましたと
はい 悟りましたというふうな悟ったようね
その意味と違いますよというぐらいのことでサンマー入れてるんです
そこでサンボーディスカっていうのは
やっぱり悟り開いたんだから
もう大変楽しみがあるんですね
その楽しみ タッサスカッサ
これらの楽しみ ネッカムスカ
パヴィヴェーカスカ サンボーディスカ
それで３つなんですね
ネッカムスカ 俗的に言えばネッカムスカっていうのは出家したことの楽しみ
パヴィヴェーカスカっていうのは瞑想して禅定を得た楽しみ
サンボーディスカっていうのは
さらに瞑想して悟りを開いた楽しみという楽しみが３つなんです
だから解脱Aに段階にランクしているんですね
出家して戒を守る それすごい楽しみなんです
戒を守るということ自体は不思議なことではなくて
この俗世間の欲に依存することをやめることは戒律なんですね
酒は飲んで楽しむことが酒はやめると
それが戒律でしょうに
だから出家イコール戒律なんですね
いろいろ美味しい料理作って食べて楽しむことをやめると
そこら辺何かいただいたもので生活するんだと
だから戒律イコール出家
ですから解脱Aの解なんですね
だから出家する 世俗世界から離れる
それ自体ですごい楽しい
だから戒律の楽しみ それだけで心は落ち着かないんですよ
今まで欲しがっていたものだからね
それで瞑想してみる そうするとサマーディが生まれてくる
そうすると心の煩悩が沈んで
平安な寂静の状態が生まれてくる
それはパヴィヴェーカスカン
サマーディの楽しみ それで止まることをしないで
もう全ての煩悩をなくして悟りを開く
それはパンニャー解脱AのAの方ですね
パンニャー得たらさらに楽しみがあるんですね
そうやって３つの楽しみがありますとということになるんです
この３つの楽しみが タッサスカッサ ニカーマラービー バヴィッサティ
スィーイミ 随意に得るってですかね
随意です 随意に 自由自在に得るものっていう意味じゃないかって
難なく得るもの 苦しまないで楽に得られるもの
ニカーマラビ まあ一応
意味は明記しないみたいですけど
まあ注釈書に沿ってこの随意に得るという風に書いてますね
だからその 3つの楽しみは
あの希望通りに得るということでね
期待通りに得ると いわゆる期待通りということで
希望通りに得られる それで次の言葉はアキッチャラービ
アキッチャラービは苦労しないで得る
楽に得られる アカシラ
カシラっていうのはほんの少々という意味で
ですからアカが入ったら少々ではないんですね
もうたくさんということになるんですね
ですからアカシララービ
もう思い存分得られる
希望通りに得る 楽に得る
思い存分 もう嫌になるほど得ると
そのような人にはなりませんと
なれません だからラービっていうのは人のことなんですね
ニカーマラビ アキッチャラービ
アカシララービ 一応そういうのはセットの用語で
もうそんなにこのきめ細かな言葉一つ一つ解釈する必要はないんです
一言葉の意味がわかればそれで十分です
同じ意味なんです だからこのニカーマというのは言語学的に分析しようと思ってもなかなか難しくて
エティモロジーっていうのはちょっとわからないんですね
ニは否定形になるし カーマラビというのはニカーマって
ニッカーマだからニッカーマ
ですからこの ちょっとエティモロジーっていうのは少々わからないんですね
だからこの邦学なさった方も
まあただ注釈の意味を書いてあって
注釈でもエティモロジーの分析はしていない
まああとはどうでもいいことで
3つの楽しみがあるんだよと
その 3つの楽しみをいとも簡単に期待通りに
それから楽に それから思い存分得られるものにはなりませんよと
誰がなりませんかというと
あのグループを楽しんで
グループと一緒にいること
老けちゃって いろんな他の違う別グループと一緒でもいることを楽しくてたまらないと
そうやって人付き合い楽しむと
もう一人でいることはもうじゃあなくて
この 3つの楽しみはもう全く得られなくなっちゃうんだよと
ネータンターナンウィッジャティ
そんなことはなくちゃありえません
不可能であると それでお釈迦様は最初にも否定形入れちゃって
ネコー ないと言って それからポジティブで文章を言っちゃいますね
またまとめて言いますけど
人付き合い好む人にとっては
この怨理の楽しみ 欲から離れた出家としての味わうべく楽しみ
それから禅定を得て心平安に寂静にして得られる楽しみ
それから悟りを開いて得られる
煩悩から完璧に消えましたと離れましたという
その智慧が開発しましたという
その楽しみ 3つがもう得られなくなるんだよと
ということで 逆に言っちゃうんです
ヨーチャコーソーアーナンダビクコーエーコーガナスマーウーパカットーヴィーラティ
タッセータンビクキューノーパーティーカンカンヤンタンネッカンアマスカンパヴィウェカスカンウパサマスカンサンボーダスカン
タッサスカッサニカーマラビーバヴィッサティアティッチャラービーアカシララービーティーターナメータンヴィッジャティー
そこでまた反対にも言う
意味が間違わないように
もうもう何回も繰り返してはっきりと言います
それでも間違うということは不思議ですけどね
これほど繰り返して言ってるんだから
逆に言うんですね ヨーチャコーソービク
もしある比丘がエーコー一人でウーパカットーヴィーラティ離れて生活するならば
こちらでこのというこの道理は知られませんと訳していますけど
ということは不可能であると
この日本訳したならばしっかりしますけどね
まあ道理を道理を知れません
知られませんでいたっても
なんか私にとってはちょっとわからないんですね
意味は やっぱアリゴーの意味はネータンターナンウィッジャティありえない
それはありえません そんなケースはありませんという
ターナンというのはケースなんですよ
そんなケースはないんだと
いわゆるみんなと楽しむ
その人はもうネッカムスグパヴィウェカスカンサンボーダスカン得られると
そんなケースはありませんというはっきりした言葉なんですね
ですから その道理は知られませんという
翻訳するよりは まあそれはありえませんと
成り立ちませんというふうに訳した方が正しいんですけどね
しかしアーナンダ一人別衆から離れて住む
その比丘は そのことが期待されます
そこで比丘がこの エーコーガナスマーウーパカットー
エーコー一人でガナスマー
このグループからウーパカットー離れてヴィーラティ生活するならば
タッサエータンビクキューノーパーティーカンカン
それにはこの可能性がありますと
何ですかというと このネッカムスグパヴィウェカスカンサンボーダスカンという 3つのスカが
いたま簡単に思い存分得られるんだよと
期待通りに楽に思い存分得られるぞということは
その比丘に対してはまあ期待できますよと
可能性ありますよ と そこでさらにあの説明
お釈迦様の説明ではなくて
仏教の話ですからね お釈迦様はそれからずっと仏教を語っていくんですよ
アーナンダ尊者に
スーアトゥアーナンダビクソーサンガニカーラーモーサンガニカーラトーサンガニカーラーマタンアヌディットーガナーラーモーガナラトーガナサンムディトースーサ
ーマサーマイカンワーカンタンチェトーウィモッティンウパサンパッジャヴィハーリッサティーアサーマイカーニワーアクッパンティーネータンターナンウィッジャティー
ソーチャコーソーアーナンダビクソーエーコーガナスマウーパカットーヴィハーティタッセータンビクノーパーティーカンカンサーマイカンワーカンタンチェトーウィ
モッティンウパサンパッジャヴィハーリッサティーアサーマイカンワーアクッパンティーターナンエータンウィッジャティーナアハンアーナンダエーカラプアンピサマヌ
パッサーミヤットラッタッサヤターヴィラッタッサルーパッサヴィパリナーマアンニャターバーワバーワナウッパッジェッヤソーカパリデーヴァドゥッカドゥーマナッスーパヤーサーで
次にお釈迦様はもう一つ説明しようとしているんですね
アーナンダは実際にそのような自然を楽しみ
死臭を楽しみ 思うんですね
死臭 別種を楽しみ そう喜ぶ比丘が時の着信で出す
あるいは不治の不動を成就して住んである
わかりやすいこと 文字は打ってますけど
どこを見ろとわからないんですね
この中どこにあるんですかね
後ろにある中には載ってないんですが
うん 多分後ろについて中なんですけど
それは表記してないんです
一番後ろにまとまってついてるんですよ
中があそこに入ってるんだな
この下にはない このあの落とし穴だったとか
時の落とし穴とかなんか
うん  そこでこの次にこの大衆と一緒に楽しんでいる比丘にこれもできませんよと言ってるんです
これって何やるとこれから説明出てくるんですね
サーマーイカンはカンタンチェトーウィモッティンウパサンパッジャヴィハーリッサティー
サーマーイカンというのは
この時間に関係あって
時のということです あっ
吹っ飛んだ ピッタさんに
時の楽心解脱って書いてある時の時と一緒に当てはめてよろしいでしょうか
何？ 日本語の方で時の楽心解脱をって書いてある時
先生がおっしゃったパーリ語の
それサマーイカン  サマーイカン
サマーイカンっていうのはそれほど難しいことではなく
時々っていうことなんです
一番後ろにまとめて書いてあるでしょ
それの6番 そこ日本語で書いてあるので
ちょっと読んで差し上げます
で あのサマーイカンっていうのは
この時間に応じてということで
そんなに難しいことではありません
で それはだいたいこの禅定のことでもあります
例えばあのお坊さんが
あの ある時は瞑想して禅定に入っているんですね
その修行中は この禅定状態だから
ものすごい心 弱情な状態で楽しんでるんです
それで禅定終わって またどこかへ行ってみんなに説法したり
何か他の仕事をしたり
お寺の掃除をやったりすると
そのサマーディがないんですよ
サマーディ状態でできるわけじゃないんですね
それで ああ もう疲れた
じゃあ瞑想でもしようかなと思って
また自分でまた瞑想して心を落ち着いてもらう
そういうサマーディのことを言ってるんです
サマーイカン えーと  それは時の楽心解脱
楽心  と日本語の  サマーイカンはアクッパンはパーリ語で
サマーイカンはカンタン チェトー イムッテン ウパサンパッジョ ヴィハレス
で カンタンっていうのは
このまあまあ楽というよりは楽しい
チェトー イムッテン 心は離れて
だからこの悟らなくたっても
煩悩がやっぱり隠れていても
瞑想している最中では瞑想がそのうまくいけば煩悩が機能しないんですよ
その瞬間ってすごい気持ちいいんですよ
その瞬間を時の心の解脱と言ってるわけですね
そうそう  ありがとうございます
その時その時 瞑想がうまくいかない時は楽しくはないんだけど
もう時々うまくいく時もありますよ
続いてる時ですね  だからまあその時はまあ結構心は煩悩がない
ヴィパッサナー瞑想の場合は何のことなく気楽にサティいられる
いられる いられることはできる
それから余計な もう雑念やら嫌な考え方と丸っきり消えてしまっちゃって
ただ体の動きだけ観察していられる
すごい穏やかで気持ちいいんですよ
まあ何か体の膨らみ縮みでも何でもいいんですけど
何かそれだけ見ながらじっと全ての雑念がなくなっちゃって
で いられる時間っていうのはものすごい最高の楽しみ時間なんで
でもちょっともう立ち上がったら
目を開けたら またもうもう心がまた概念の世界で活動し始めるんですよ
だからそれでまた疲れたなと思ったら
また瞑想に入ったらまたよろしいし
そういう人々にも禅定能力あるんだったら
まあその禅定能力を持って
いとも簡単にその心の平安状態を作ることができます
でもそれは瞑想中のみなんです
瞑想終わったらまあ普通なんですね
それはサマーイカン カンタン チェトー イムッテンということなんです
時間に時間の制限があるということで
次のサマーディはアサマーイカンはアクッパン
アサマーイカンというのは時間と関係ない
アクッパンっていうのはこのアンチェンジャブル
リバーティブル イレバーシブルという英語で言うこの変えられない
ということで 時間と関係ない
またイレバーシブル リバースすることはできませんというサマーディ
まあこちら不動ですね
書いてることがっていうのはね
富士の不動って書いてありますので
だから富士  富士が動かない
富士っていうのは時間と関係ないということで
不動でもう確定しているので
それはこの悟りのことなので
煩悩がもう死んでしまった
煩悩が死んでしまったら
禅定があるかないかと関係なく
仕事をしようが掃除洗濯しようが
もう貪瞋痴が出てこないんですね
だから悟った人にとっては
もうずっと心は寂静状態にあるんです
仕事をしたっても 何やったっても
もうこの人は嫌な人やとか
また出てこないんですね
サマーディだけ瞑想中だけ機嫌が良くて良い人はもう嫌な人を喋っていると
またどんどんどんどんもう怒りやらね
もう出てきて まあ疲れてしまって嫌な気持ちになるんで
それで本当に嫌だ 今日は1日はダメでしたと思って
またもうなんとか瞑想でもしようかなと来て瞑想すると
それはサーマイカ 時間に限るサマーディ
もし悟り開いたら煩悩そのものが死んじゃいますから
サマーディあるかないかと関係なく
心には悩み苦しみがないんですね
それはアクッパチェトームッティと言うんですね
イレバイレバッシブル
リバースできないサマーディと
誰にもこれはいじることはできません
もう安定しています という
もう確固たるサマーディのことなんですね
で まあ専門的になんていうか
すごい簡単なことで 時の安らぎっていうのはサマーディ瞑想の世界で時と関係ないサマーディっていうのは悟りのことで
だからサマーディとパンニャーのことなんですね
普通のサマーディ瞑想すると確実に心は寂静状態にはなります
でも瞑想するときに限る
それで瞑想したっても
サマーディに入られるか入らないかと
体の状況もいろいろ条件もあります
瞑想上手な人にしても
いつでも簡単にサマーディに入れるということでもありません
で 体調が悪かったらダメになっちゃうとかいろいろありますよ
ですから 時の様 条件によります
それでサマーディに入って 1 日 2
日  3日  4日入れると これまた論理的にまだ不可能です
心の法則なんですよ 禅定に入ったっても
どれくらい時間かということはまた決まってるんです
それは訓練して訓練して
10 分サマーディ状態で 20 分いられる
30 分いられるということはできますけどね
で それほど長くっていうのは無理なんですね
心はまたサマーディをやめて普通に回転し始めるんですね
だからそれたとえで言えば
何か玉投げ石投げみたいなもので
訓練すればするほど どれぐらい遠く投げれるかということはもうあるんですけど
どれほど訓練したっても
投げた球はどこかで落ちなくてはならないんですよ
ですから 全然もう訓練してない子供は球を投げたらそこら辺に落ちちゃうし
大人が力ある人を投げれば
それまたちょっと行ってどこかに落ちるかもしれませんし
で 本当にすごい能力のある天才的なピッチャーとかね
もう誰かさんがね もうなければもうかなり遠くへ行っていくかもしれませんだけど
それでも落ちるんです
サマーディの場合は そうやって人の訓練次第で何時間禅定状態にいられるかということはあるんですけど
必ずしもそこにはストップはあります
ですから 時との関係は全く否定できません
ですから 解釈する中で
仏教はこのインドのヒンドゥー世界の瞑想にすぎなくても否定はしていない
あなた方の解釈をやらそうな哲学は全部ダメやと
瞑想はダメやと言わないんです
瞑想は瞑想でちゃんと修行しなきゃできるもんではなりませんし
宗教は違っても その人々も欲から離れて
ものすごい苦労して清らかな心で瞑想しているんだから
それはそれでよろしいと
でも変な解釈するなよと
あなた方の哲学はもうゴミも同じものやと
だから彼らが一回その統一状態が得たら
それから死後永遠にいられるんだぞと
どんな証拠にもあるわけじゃないんですね
頑張ってみなさいと ある時間決まってるでしょうと
その時間終わったらすぐ心が普通の次元に落ちるんではないか
そこでこの最高にできるのは一週間なんですよ
それも完全に悟った人に限るんです
完全に悟った人だけ禅定に入って
そのままで 1週間いられる
でも 8 日間はいられません
そこら辺をお釈迦様は全部実験済みで
経験済みでおっしゃっていることなんです
だから誰かが 1ヶ月間も飲まず食わず禅定中いた
それは嘘ですよ ありえないんです
まあ体は動かさないで 1 日中でもいられますけど
サマー瞑想できる人にとってはね
でも禅定状態は 1 日中ずっと続くということはないんです
で 一旦禅定に入って そのスピードが終わったら
また元の心に戻って でも禅定は知ったばっかりだから
体格 体はもう体調は最高な状態にあるんですよ
痛い痒いとかね そんなもの何もない
細胞にしても 心落ち着いてた方が一番ありがたい状態だから
もう細胞も線細胞もすごい上手い上手い状態に整えてはいるんですね
それでそのまままた瞑想初めからやって
またもう一回入ってみると
それはあり得るんです
それで 1 日いることはできます
じゃあもう一回やるぞと
で またそのサマーディはまたじゃあもう一回やるぞということはできますけど
それで 1 日中ずっと禅定状態にいたかというと
それはありえません で
それはもう心の法則ですからね
だから心の法則は分かっていない人々はいろんなことを言っているのではないかということ
大体だからこのサマーディというか
ヨガの世界でね たった一回はなんとか変なことを経験しなさいということだけにチャレンジしているんですね
たった一回もう爆発したんだとかね
もう光が現れたとかね
まあそれでもやったぞと言って証明書を出すんですね
笑っちゃう で あの何宗教でしたっけ
あれはハレーラーマとかね
あの人々のパンフレットとか見ると
このもうとにかくいたずら歌う
何年も歌う もう 1 日中歌う
歌もものすごい単純で
1 行だけしか言葉もないし
ハレーラーマハレークリシュナただそれだけ
それ 1 日歌うんだから
それを踊りながら歌う
それでパーとなっちゃうんだと
それが盆賀一念やと それでイラストいっぱい描いて
もうやらせるんですよ
だからそんなことをずっとやっちゃうと
かなり脳細胞破壊されちゃってね
バカになる可能性っていうのはどうせありますし
だから日常生活でもなんとなくなんかこの世知らないという感じでいますけど
それは一つマインドコントロールみたいなもんで
その中でも本当にこのもう光が見えちゃって
なんか自分が消えた瞬間というようなことはありえないわけじゃないんですよ
でもそんなものとは 仏教の言っている瞑想っていうのはものすごい違う世界なんですね
それはどう言ってもサマーディ方向に入っちゃうし
サマーディ悪いというわけじゃないんです
サマーディが煩悩が機能するとは生まれません
どうしても だからやり方は
たとえ変でインチキであろうとも
そのやり方によって一応貪瞋痴が進んでしまって
もうサマーディ 一時的な瞬間的なサマーディっていうのは生まれる可能性はあります
でも瞬間的ですよ なぜならば
方法っていうのはすごいいい加減だから
彼らもね もう菜食主義でベジタリアンで
もうあまり食べないで
もういろいろ服装も変えて
変な服装 頭を全部剃って
真ん中だけ長い髪 ほんのちょっとだけ残して
それでもう体中灰やらいろんなものを塗ってね
で いろいろ刺激的に この東京で言ったら新宿のところとかね
渋谷とか そういうもうド派手なところで歌って踊ったりするんですね
だからこの 特に西洋人にとっては
そういうところで一番品のない
一番変な姿で 形で 一番気持ちかっこ悪い
恥ずかしいことをやること自体が心にすごいショックなんですよ
で 踊ったりするんだからね
で そういうことで心がどんどんどんどん変わってね
まあ自分たちが違うんだと
この俗世間に この若者をね
まあド派手にロックやらいろんな音楽を踊って聞いている我々はもう違います
離れているんだぞとかね
そうやって強引にこの理欲の刺激をね
心に与えてあげて で それでなんか瞬間的に何か変な神秘体験というやつですけどね
で 生まれる可能性も明らかにあります
でなきゃそんなやらないんだからね
でもまあまあ  100人に 200人
300人に一人 それほど珍しいんで
それでもないんですからね
ああ なんでしょうかね
あのインドで有名なあの人が
オショーという若者なんですけど
あの人のところでももう悟ったという人がっているの2 3
人しかいないんだから
もう世界中信者さんいるでしょうに
億万長者でしょうに その人も死んじゃったんですけど
とにかくそんな大した頭のいい人ではないんですけど
西洋人にとってはすごい天才だからしょうがないんですけど
インド人から見ればただのそこら辺にいるじじいで何の変わりもないんです
で だからこれもう これはインド文化系の人でないとわからないところいっぱいあるんですよ
この思考パターンというの
我々にとってはガキにもできる思考パターンなんですけど
それは上手な英語でなんとか言っちゃうと
みんな驚いてもう繰り返しちゃうんです
もう でも私たちから見れば
もう何だ何やと もっとすごい知恵があるんじゃないかと
まあだからそれはまあ文化的な問題でね
まあインド文化系の人以外はこれちょっとわからないんですよ
ですから 我々嫉妬してるわけでも
何度もインドの行ってみたっても
サイババなんかベースに相手にしないんですね
ああそう サイババ まあまあ彼も頑張ってるんじゃないかと
それで終わっちゃうんですね
否定もしないし だからすごいということでもないんですね
そんな人とはそっちへいるんだよ
そこら辺に どこでもということで
あんまりね もうだって言ってる話を聞いたってもね
子供でも言ってることだから
インドにいますよ あの子供たち学校に行かないんだけど
いくらか英語をなんとか喋られるとかね
ちょっと喋ってみてください
サイババが言ってることと同じもの
もしかするともっとしっかりしたこと
探知力のあることは言うんですよ
それはもう文化でみんな知ってます
[紙の音]だからこれはね
まああの 私は一回インドに行ったんだからね
その時やっぱり私はこうやって目を見ただけでも
お互いにもう全部もう思考パターンからなんだかんだ知ってるんだから
店に行ったらもう言うんですね
で まあ私はヒンディー語やら何から全部知ってると勘違いする
それは知らないんだけど
思考は知ってる 何考えるか
何企んでるかって だから商売と言えば九十九点九九パーセントインチキやってる
ごまかしやってる だからまあそちらへんを私は知ってるんだから
もう決して言った値段では買わない
百ルピーで言ったら いきなり十ルピーだったら買うんだけどっていう
いきなりもう十にするんです
百ルピーが十になるわけないでしょ
なります それはいかに論争して勝てるかということによります
物には値段ないんです
インドでは それは一生懸命手作りした品物かもしれませんよ
その人にとっては それは誰か欲しい人には持っていけということでも構いませんし
それでいいんじゃないかと
あいつは喜んだんだからと
それですごい良いことしたと喜ぶし
それが誰かが十ルピーくれるんだったら
あーよかった 十ルピーもらったぞということになりますし
で 日本人が言ったら これは三百ルピーだよと
で いきなり言うかもしれません
だから物には値段ないんですよ
とにかく それは即席人が決めるんです
だから日本人がこの手作りで
これやっぱり日本だったらこれもうもう本当に二万円になるんじゃないかなとかね
だからじゃあ自分百ルピーで頼もうかなとかね
これ一万ぐらいだから
これ儲かったもんやと
で 百ルピーで言うかもしれません
いや だからこの人はそれで百五十ルピーと言うでしょうね
それでねじって じゃあ百ルピーでいいやと
それでこちら儲かったという感じで帰っちゃうし
あの人も百ルピーもらったということになるし
そちらに私が行って これでタダでくれと言ったらタダでもらうこともできます
それでその人損失だから
全然そう思ってないんです
百ルピーで売れるのに
この人にタダであげるわけにはいきませんということは成り立たないんです
だからその思考っていうのは
その文化圏でないとちょっとわからないんですよ
だから わざと必ず金儲かるという
この金に価値入れてないんですよ
人は人のために仕事をする
それはカルマヨガ ヨガなんですよ
そこで自分がした仕事は
誰かがそれを取っちゃえば
それで自分の仕事は完了しているんです
それで終わりです そこでお前に食うものないでしょ
じゃあこれで何か食べなさい
ありがとうございます
という これは別の話になっちゃうんですね
それで西洋的な商売の世界になってくると
もうやりたい放題 インド人になっちゃう
だからアメリカに制裁されちゃって
全然あ そうということで終わるんだから
別にそんなことやってない
もともとやってないんだから
負けません そんなことでということ
だからインドは貧しい国か豊かな国かさっぱりわからないんですよ
インドの軍事力見たら
もう日本っていうのも当てはめないと思いますよ
すごい軍事力 何でもありと
だからといって見たらもう乞食ばっかり
どんな国かとさっぱりわからないという国なんですね
面白いって言ったらすごい面白い国なんですけどね
ですから 私が言ったのは
日本人と商売やってるんだから
まずあんたは何も喋らないでくださいと言うんですね
そう先に言われるとどうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
私は黙って じゃあどうぞ自由にやってくださいと
あんまりにもやられると思っちゃう
いくらでも私は日本人と一緒に生活している人だから
なんかどこかでちょっと気になるってこともありますけど
言えないんですね これ
日本語で言ったっても
やっぱりもうすぐ分かってしまうという
だからもうものすごく隠れて
まあその値段で買うなよとかなんとか言わないとおかないとね
言わないでおかないと
そこで店に入る前にね
その言う値段でちょっと買った方がいいよと
ちょっと隠れて行ったって
それからまた自分たちはプロになりきっちゃうんですね
プロになりきったってなれません
どうしてもやられちゃいます
私はまあまあ買わなかったんで
一回だけまあジュースでしたっけ？これくらいバカでかいタバコに一枚四ドルか五ドルで売ってるのね
これぐらい束なんですけどね
もう二百本ぐらいあったんだけど
全部まとめて十ドルで買ったんですけど
で もう私はただまあその男の子がすごい明るくて
もうかなりもう可愛いんですよ
で 買いたいなら話し方やらね
もう全然人に遠慮はしないし
すごく仲良く喋るという
で そんなに英語がヘラヘラってわけでもないんですけど
それで言ったらもうちょっと買ってくれる
川上は前の品物ってなんかくだって言わないかと
というんですけど そこで品物ではなくて
そいつは私と仲良く喋ってるだけのことなんですね
それはもうその人は諦めないんですよ
今ちょっと散歩するんだからね
うるさいし もう黙っていろよ
うるさいんだからって言ったら
もうそこでほんのちょっと待ってて
またまた探し始めると
そこであっちこっち行く行くところに持ってくる
もう買わんだから だったら自分の値段言ってくださいと
だから私は値段言いませんと私は言うんです
なんで？だって値段を言うのは
私は買いたいんだったら値段言うでしょ
買いたくないんだから
だからそこで論争なんですよ
結局は  You tell the price.
I don't tell the price because I don't want to come.
I don't want to buy. 日本語で難しいんですよ
で そうやってもう買えないと
すごい単純な英語でやり取りやっていたんですけど
もう値段言えませんと
向こうは単にとにかく何か値段言ってくれと
もし値段言っちゃったらこちらの負けなんですよ
この論争で値段言ったということは
物に値段をつけたということで
もう買う気持ちはそこで表してるんですよ
そこでそちらはその値段に負けるか
また上げるかということで
向こうの商売になっちゃうんで
もう戦いになっちゃうんです
もうずっとやってて 最後にもう帰りますよと
バスに乗って帰るときで
それでもやって それで私の心の中で
こいつとすごい長い間喋っていたんだから
なんとかあげたい気持ちはもうあるんですよ
もうもう親しみが出ているんだからね
だから物を売っても売れなくても
いくらかお金はあげたい
もう別にもう何のことなくお金はあげたい
ただそれだけ で それでちょっと時間も挙げて
10ドルだったら買いますよと
買うんだったら全部買うんだけどね
まとめてね  1本でくっだらないと価値もないんだと
全部まとめて 10ドルだったら買っちゃうんだけど
そこは何を言うんでしょうかと
どう？ 40ドルでもいいんだけど
まあはい  40ドル はいはい
分かりました 終わり そこでバスってもうエンジンもかけて
もうドア閉まる瞬間で
じゃあ 10ドルでいいですよ
でも大量にボンドも使わなかったし
もうもう全然通ったことない
1本日本人が10万円でも買いますけどね
まあそれは余計な話でね
まあ一応まあそんな世界なんですね
向こうの だからもう で
まあそれで まあそういう世界ではね
やっぱりサマーディ瞑想っていうのはかなりあることは確かにあるし
そういういろんな人がいろんな形であのサマーディ瞑想をやって
商売にする人々もいるし
かなり値段つけたりしてね
だから値段つけない人々はそれをすごく嫌がっちゃうんですよ
インドでも外国人に会う人々はみんなやっぱり値段つけてますね
自分の瞑想に だからまあ
だからインド文化系の人々っていうのは全然あてにしない
そんなもうメディテーションビジネスではないかと
株式会社 ということで
聖者とはあまり考えませんね
メディテーション 株式会社ですからね
いろいろサイババにしても
サイババメディテーション
サイババでしょ だからまあそんなことをこういうところ言ったら非常に失礼なことだと思いますけど
インドでは別に失礼でも何でもないんですね
そんなこと言う必要もないってことになっちゃうんですね
で 私たちはそういう批判のやり方だからといって彼を否定しているわけじゃないんです
彼もそれなりに一生懸命社会福祉やらもういろんなことをやっている
これはすごくいいことじゃないかと
だから応援しましょうというところもあるんです
応援しましょうというところもあって
やっぱりサイババはサイババ
だからそこはちょっと西洋思想とはね
違うところで批判したんだからといって
その人はもうきれいさっぱり処分という悪魔やという風にはなりません
そんな善悪判断というのはあまりつけない世界なんですね
インド教にしても善と悪とそんなにあまり区別はしない
それその辺 すごく普通のここの人々にはちょっと理解しにくいんですよ
善悪区別しないんだからって
悪人じゃないって全くとんでもないんだよ
悪人でもなんでもないんですけど
でも人を騙せますけどね
だから仏教負けちゃうのはそういうことなんですね
仏教は本当に正直ですよ
だからそういうことさえも否定するんですね
徹底的に だから純粋な綺麗というところを目指していますね
インド人にばかにされちゃうんですね
あなた方にはもう生きていられませんよと
確実に だから生きていられません
最もオープンでやらなくてはいかんと
いいんじゃないかと それでもという感じなんですね
例えばジリジリとヒンドゥー寺院であの
何て言いますか プリーストやってる人が出てきて
私は仏教徒でもありますよと言って
仏教の人々からお布施もらったりしちゃうと
誰かが我々仏教なんてことをするんで
それ悪いんです いいんじゃないですか
それぐらいでというふうな感じなんですね
仏教徒はそれを認めないんですよ
だから だから仏教のお坊さんたちも
ヒンドゥー的な何かお供え物とか
なんとかみんなにしてあげて
何か施食してお金もらったりする
ヒンドゥーの人々は反対しません
どうそうどうそうってことになっちゃうんで
仏教はそれやりません
我々は仏教徒だからと
だったらあなた方は生きていられませんと
ということになっちゃう
だからそれは物質的な世界にしても
精神的なことになっても同じことなんですね
精神的なことにしたっても
もうヴィッシュの神にお供え物を持ってきながら
もしかするとじゃあ瞑想もしてみましょうということにもなるんですね
それはまあそういう文化なんですよ
とにかく一応精神文化ですね
中国も中国ももうものすごい巨大な文化でしょうし
だからそちらは厳密に物質文化にも統一しているでしょうし
それに対立してインドっていうのは厳密に精神文化に統一しているんですね
だから例えば中国文化を見ると
もう何でも縁起があるかないかとというところにすごい厳密なんですね
何でも縁起がいいもの
ご利益のあるものというふうな
その哲学に統一されているんです
それで仏教も受けていますけど
仏教いろいろやればかなり縁起がいいということで認めると
悟りとかそんなものあんまり
それもやってますけどね
シンガポールなんか行っても
ちょっとタクシーに乗ったって
もうほんのちょっと10分車で行ったって
もうガチャガチャ喋りますよ
向こうは まあそれで英語通じますから
すごい便利ですけど やっぱり仏教の人々ってかなり深く勉強はしているんですね
勉強はしているんだけど
全て日常生活に当てはめちゃうんですね
完全に 例えば欲のない世界
怒りのない ある人が物事をどう見ればかと
これはもう貪瞋痴なく
全て無常で変化しているものだから
何も執着してはいけないということで
厳密に若者なんですけど
どこかの法事があって車を運転してくれたんですよ
他の坊さんたちはちょっとあまり話に乗らなくて
それで私はしょうがないってことで彼とも喋っていたんですけど
ものすごい難しい仏教の内容をものすごく言うんですね
それでいて それでそういう論理だから
私はもう会社でもこういうことになってくると
こういう風に 奥さんと色々出て
こういう風に やっぱり結局は全て自分の毎日の生き方にピッタリはめてもらうという
で 教えが知らないかと問うではないか
ものすごい深く厳密に物事の見方やら無常であることやら
因果法則やら もう何から何までよく勉強していると
よく勉強していて 会社で友達関係で
奥さんとその先生関係であらゆるトラブルが起こらなくて
何も執着なくやることやるんだよと
ということでストレスなんですね
それで でもそれをわかっただけではダメだから瞑想もするんだと
だから瞑想もする そんな文化ですよ
だからまあインドはインドで
もうだから我々は一応伝道師としてのね
まあもう資格ですからね
それはもうどんな人の文化にも
どこまで広げていて どこまでできるかっていうことはね
まあ寸地にキャッチしますけど
だからまあ西洋人にもアメリカ人にも何のことなく喋れますけどね
そう 誰でもどこまで持っていくかってことも知っています
どうやって解釈するかと
それ そこまで喋ったのはサマーディのことなんですけど
サマーディっていうのは一応一時的っていうのは仏教の立場なんですね
だからそれサマーディそのものを否定してダメということではなくて
実際にサマーディ状態に入る時間というのは決まってます
ですから まあそれは球を投げることと同じく
どれぐらい上手かっていうことによって
どれぐらい距離投げられるかっていうことで
それで人によってサマーディに入っていられる時間は長いと短いとかいろいろあります
そんなものは気にする必要はないんです
とにかく まあたとえ 1 分でもサマーディができれば
ものすごい極端な安らぎを
喜びを得られる それが一つ
それから心に波を作るのは貪瞋痴だから
貪瞋痴そのものがもう根絶してしまえば
特別なサマーディ なんとかなくても
その人はずっともう平安な状態でいられる
それが不動な不二の 不二不動の安らぎなんですね
だからそれはパンニャーの解浄栄の場合は栄の世界
そこでこのグループを楽しむ人にとっては
この有限的なサマーディも楽しむもないし
無限的 有限 それおかしいね
いわゆる時間的な安らぎもないし
時間と関係ない不動な安らぎももう関係ない
ありえませんというところなんですね
そこでもし誰か比丘が
グループから離れているならば
一人で生活しているならば
その人には一時的な安らぎも得られるし
不当な安らぎも得られるんだよと
それからお釈迦様はまた項目出すんですよ
次の経典の進む進むために
今までおっしゃったのは
こんなみんなとわいわいとやるなよと
それがもう心の成長には危険だよと
みんなと仲良くグループ作っていること自体は
あんた方わかってないだけで
そんなすごい品のないレベルの低い楽しみ
もう刺激だけで全然成長しませんよ
グループから離れていた方がいろんな大変なことができますよということで
一つのポイントを置いておいて
次に説法に必要な次のポイントというか項目は次に出すんですね
それはナ
ハンアナンダエカルーパンピサマヌパッサーミヤッカラッタッサヤタービラッタッサルーパッサヴィパッリナーマアンニャターバーナウッパジャヨンソーカパリデーワドゥッカドーマナッスーパーヤーサー
で こちらこのルーパのことで
ルーパって言えば形なんですけど
色ですけど でも注釈書ではルーパっていうのは体ですよと
それであの一つもルーパがありませんと
一つも体がありませんという
とにかくパーリ語で動詞先に言っちゃいますから
日本語で理解するのは難しくなっちゃいますけど
一応我々にとっては動詞ははっきり先に言った方がもうまるっきり誤解なし
きちんとイエスノーするんですよ
ですから 英語との違いは
英語よりもものすごい緊密にこのイエスノーをはっきりさせちゃうんですよ
そのために同義語までいっぱい使っちゃうんですね
あんたこれでわからなかったらこの言葉でいかがでしょうかと
だからダラダラと同義語がたくさん出てきて
繰り返し文句も出てきて
一回で否定で終わらないので
二 三回否定するんです
それでも否定したことにならないかということになっちゃうんですね
だからこの誤解するのは私はなんでだとわからないほど
こんなにもうるさいほどはっきり言ってるんだからね
一回だけで終わらないんですよ
もう二 三回 五 六回 違いますよ
違いますよと言うんだからね
だから例えばグループと一緒にいちゃうと何も得られませんと何回言ったんですかね
この中で何回も繰り返しちゃう
経典の中で私はたくさん言ったかもしれませんだけど
経典の中でも何回も繰り返しちゃうんですね
そこでこのナハンアナンダエーカンルーパンピサマヌパッサミー
ナハンとありませんというところから始まるんですね
サマヌパッサミー 私は見つかりません
私は見つかりませんと言って次に言うんです
何よと 一つの体も それから続けるんですね
ヤッタラッタッサ 一つの体でも見つかりません
どんな体で その体にラッタッサ欲を作る
あ いいものやと好みを作っちゃうと
それにもふけてしまう
注釈書によると体なんですけどね
例えば私は一つの体も見出せません
見つかりません どんな体でと
誰々がある体にものすごく欲を出す
ものすごく楽しいと綺麗やと
それにふけてしまうと
この体はなんて美しいかとふけたとしますね
そこで その人のそのルーパッサヴィパッリナーマアンニャターバーヴァ
このルーパが その体がヴィパッリナーマ変化する
アンニャターバーヴァ変わっていく
だから体だから必ずしも変化する
変わっていく そこでナウッパジャヨンソーカパリデーワドゥッカドーマナッスーパ
苦しみ 悩み 憂い 悲しみが生まれないということは絶対あり得ませんということなんです
だからね そこでまたすごい回りで否定という否定形入れて入れて否定するんですね
簡単で言えば いかなる体に対してもすごい執着すると
その体が変わると悲しみが生まれますよということ
それは全部否定形で言うんですね
ある体に執着して老けていると
その体が変化すると 決して悲しみ
悩み 憂いが生まれないということは決してありえないと
そのような体は私は見つかりませんという風に
もう否定形をバラバラまくんです
すごく強調するんですね
だから意味はそんなに複雑な意味というわけではないので
これはもう文法的にもうはっきり説明する
しておく お釈迦様こういうこと
だからルーパは体でよろしいか私もわかりませんですけど
これで省略しているんだからね
すべての現象かもしれませんしね
で だからグループで楽しんでいることだから
やっぱり人を楽しんでいるんで
あの人はいい この人もいい
この人も楽しいとかね
で そんなふうなことかもしれませんし
それでその人々 体のことを楽しんでいるんでしょうしね
ルーパを喜ぶということ
でも体のことを楽しんでいると
その体は必ずしも変化する
変わる 面白いことを喋る人でも
ずっと面白いことを言っているわけじゃないんですよ
面白くないものも言う場合もあるし
で それでこの変化すると
自分の心には悲しみ 苦しみが生まれてきます
例えば 自分がすごい可愛いと思っていたもの
鳥でもよろしいし 犬猫でもよろしいし
もうなんて可愛いんですかと思って買っていたその鳥でも猫でも
もう年取ってボロボロになったところで悲しくないと
全然悲しくないと言えますかね
それはありえないんだ
それで死んでしまっちゃう
悲しくなるでしょうと
だからルーパに対しては
それはもう確実にあること
たとえ鳥を飼っていて
ああ可愛い可愛いと そこを鳥と遊ぶことを楽しんでいる人が
鳥が死んでしまっちゃうと
病気になっちゃうと 餌を食べなかった
食べなかっただけでもすごい心配するんでしょうに
そこで死んでしまっちゃうと
もうショック受けちゃうでしょうに
だからそこでポイントは何なのかと
なんで余計にそれに執着したんです？放っておけばよかったのに
鳥はもう野生で勝手に生活して
勝手にいくらでも死ぬでしょうに
そんなことはそっちの鳥たちが死ぬ
でも悲しみがないでしょう
猫たちもあっちこっちにそこら中死んでいるでしょうに
全然悲しくもなんでもないんです
でも その中で 1匹の猫
これは私の可愛い猫ちゃんやと執着したところで
並ならぬ悲しみが生まれてくるんですよ
世の中でいくらでもそうやって死んだりするのは
ごく普通な現象で 珍しくても何でもない
なのにそれによって人間が執着することによって
ただそれだけのことで悲しんじゃうんではないかと
だからそれから離れちゃうと何のこともない
だから悲しみ 悲しみたくければ
上になりたく なりたいと思うならば
とても簡単です 鳥一羽ではなくて 2 3
羽飼っちゃうと もっと増えるんだから悲しみが
だから我が物 私のもの
ああ可愛いという風に執着して
それのその楽しみにふけちゃうと
もう精神的なショックは必ず
だからこれは余計なことなんですよ
聖ダンマで故事がありますよ
蛇を自分で捕まえてポケットに入れるもんだと
自分で蛇を捕まえて自分のポケットに入れたところで
あ 怖いと 噛まれたらやばいと
いで苦しみます だから自分でやった余計なことしなかったら別にそんなに怯えて生活する必要ないでしょうにと
だから余計なことに手を出す
出してバカを見る場合は
そのたとえを使うんですよ
蛇を取ってポケットに入れたんだと
蛇だと思わかったら放っておけばいいんです
そこら辺で蛇はもうネズミとかカエルとかね
捕って食べて生活してるんだから
別にどうったことはない
そこをわざわざ追っていって捕まえて
それで自分のポケットに入れちゃうと
もう歩けなくなっちゃう
ちょっとでもびっくりしちゃったらすぐ噛んでしまいますから
で 噛まれたらもうそれでもう命が危なくなっちゃうし
そういうふうに我々はこの眼耳鼻舌身意
もう外の世界のものはとにかく
はい これもいただき これもあれもいただき
これもいただきとか いろんなものを自分でものをいっぱいいただいて生活すると
もうその分はもう苦しんでくださいってことになっちゃうんです
ものは変化するんだから
だからせっかく出家したその比丘たちも
もうグループで仲良く楽しがっているんだから
まあそれであんた方は余計なことをやって苦しんでいるのではないかっていう
で そこら辺に終了いたします
[経典の読み上げ]ではどうもありがとうございます